-I'm so happy you're here.
Thank you for
coming back on the show.
-I'm happy to be here.
-Happy to have you in person.
Last time you were on,
we were Zooming.
-Oh, my God.
-Remember that?
-Oh, yeah.
-Remember the Zoom days?
-And I was trying to
quiet my dog
in the back and do everything.
-By the way, the puppy --
I wanted to talk about this,
'cause this is your puppy.
You just got this during the --
Look at how cute.
Bailey.
-That was a pandemic dog.
-I mean, come on.
Which one is the stuffed animal?
-And now he's grown.
-Yeah. And then look.
Bailey grown up. Look.
Wow.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And how is puppy?
-Bailey has taken over.
-Just has, right?
-Bailey's taken over
the whole house.
He knows how to open doors.
He knows how to go to the pantry
to sneak snacks.
And then Bailey --
We got him dog food.
He was like,
"I don't want that [bleep]
-He grew up fast.
-"Y'all have an organic diet.
I want organic food, too."
Now we have Farmer's Dog.
-Oh, my God.
-We got it on rotation.
-Gourmet dog now.
-Bailey goes to the vet.
-Oh, my God.
Bailey drives himself?
-No, we drive him,
but at this point,
I'm looking at those vet bills
and I'm like,
"When I had a dog when I was a
kid, our dog ate Alpo."
-Yeah, of course.
-If that.
There was sometimes when
I was like,
"I don't know
what the hell my dog ate."
-Yeah, now the dog
has Uber Eats.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I was giving your intro,
and just what a great intro.
I mean, you've won an Oscar,
an Emmy, a Golden Globe, a Tony.
You've won everything.
I mean, well deserved.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Giant movie this weekend.
But you're also a number-1
"New York Times"
best-selling author.
Congratulations to Viola Davis.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You know what?
The only thing I could think
about with this book is,
my daughter's always saying,
"Mom, you've got a god complex."
So, I can't --
But I'm very proud of the book.
That's all
I'm going to say, Genesis.
-Yes.
I love that this has been
number 1 for weeks now,
"New York Times" best seller.
-Yes.
-Is it hard to write a memoir?
Is it therapeutic to
write a memoir?
-It is terrifying,
because you're outing people.
And I wanted to call people
by their names,
because I just want to say,
"Look what you did to me
when I was 6 years old."
But I couldn't do it
because, you know,
I don't want to be sued.
-Yeah, of course.
-You know, so...
-Yeah, so you had to change
some of the names, yeah.
-But it is incredibly cathartic,
especially because
I wrote it during the pandemic.
So I was like...
-Yeah. Yeah, exactly.
And you got it all out.
-I left it all on the floor.
-But what a great story.
-Yes.
-And it starts with --
But look at how --
Look at this cute little girl.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
I mean, come on.
Look at what she's done.
Now, you start like
a little kid,
and now here you are
"The Woman King."
Here you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Big deal.
-It is a big deal.
-This is a big movie.
Everyone is saying
this is the event movie
we've been
waiting for now, right?
-It's the event movie.
Let me tell you something.
I was 56 when I trained to be
this warrior, now.
Five hours a day.
Hour and a half
of weight training,
three and a half hours
of martial arts,
punching, 10.0 on the treadmill.
This is the god complex.
-Wow!
That's what I'm talking about!
10.0.
-And as I was running on that
treadmill, Jimmy, I said,
"I'm gonna have
a damn heart attack."
-No, no, no.
Look at how good you look,
though, in the movie.
I mean, come on. Look at this.
Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That one shot of you flying
in the air with the machete --
it's just iconic.
-Listen, if you ever need --
You know,
anybody ever bothers you,
I mean, I can take care of it.
-Yeah, Viola Davis,
I'll call you first.
But you've got to be
proud of that.
That's an iconic scene already,
before the movie is out.
I go, "Oh, yeah,
for the rest of your life."
And then I was
talking to you backstage.
You said it took you
seven years to make this?
-Seven years.
-Wow.
-Just fought for seven --
But you know what?
It takes long to make
any movie in Hollywood.
-True.
-It really, really does.
You're fighting for everything.
You're fighting for the actors.
You're fighting --
And then, when you're finally
on that soil --
Because we shot in South Africa.
-I mean, come on.
-And there is nothing --
And the girls, the women
in the audience knows,
there is nothing like looking at
a 250-pound man with a machete
coming at you, and you know
that, in two seconds or less,
you're gonna
have to defend yourself.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And the only thing I could
think -- I was like, "Pssss!"
-What are you talking about?
-I mean, it's terrifying.
And then they yell "action,"
and that's it.
-Yeah.
-You are on that man.
You have your sword, he has his,
and you've got to do it.
You've got to
take care of yourself.
-You are a badass in this movie.
It is unbelievable.
-Mm-hmm.
-It is iconic.
Right now, it is at 100%
on Rotten Tomatoes.
100% fresh.
So congratulations on that.
Great reviews.
But, I mean, this is --
-But you've got see it, because
let me tell you something.
Now, you can attest to it.
-Yeah.
-From the very moment the
movie opens, you are on a ride.
-Yes.
-It is a movie for everybody.
-Yeah, people screaming.
-And, I mean --
-Was it the
Toronto Film Festival?
-Toronto Film Festival.
My daughter saw it.
And my daughter was crying.
This was, you know,
after the god complex, you know.
-She's like, "Yeah, it doesn't
help your god complex."
-My daughter is at her
eye-rolling stage, okay?
She's like --
I mean, even when she said,
"Mom, you got a god complex,"
I said, "Oh, my God, Genesis.
I do not have a god complex."
She was like,
"Alexa, define god complex."
And then, after I heard it,
I was like, "Oh, my God.
I have a god complex."
-Yeah,
I actually have one, yeah.
-But, you know,
after the movie, she said,
"Mommy, I'm so proud of you."
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-But they said
the applause was so crazy
for the first minute
in the movie.
Once you came on the screen,
everyone went nuts.
And it was like -- That must
have been exciting, right?
-That must -- I'm telling you --
And, first of all,
I mean, I know I say it,
but there is nothing
that can be said about
being 56 and running at 10.0
on the treadmill.
And, I mean,
literally every day was like...
[ Breathing deeply ]
-But it's worth it.
You don't see that.
-To see it on the screen,
I'm like, "I did that."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it will live forever.
-Yes.
-Congratulations.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Viola Davis in
"The Woman King."
Take a look at this.
[ Drums playing, chanting ]
-When the wind blows,
our ancestors push us
to march into battle
against those who enslave us.
[ All shouting ]
When it thunders,
our ancestors demand
we rip the shackles of doubt
from our minds
and fight with courage.
We fight not just for today,
but for the future.
We are the spear of victory.
We are the blade of freedom.
[ All chanting ]
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
Yes!
Do you feel it?!
Viola Davis, everybody!
"The Woman King" opens in
theaters this Friday.
Karamo joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.